bonjour à tous les jours je vous ai fait
une vidéo de toxines du félin lite on a
regardé ce produit on la déballer on a
regardé ce qu'il y avait à l'intérieur
de la boîte
s'il était cool oui ou non et
aujourd'hui on faire autre chose en
faire un test un peu plus complet
pourrait regarder ce qui se paie 20
light
au final et bien oui donc on va regarder
on peut faire avec on regarde et comment
ils tournent loes les photos la vidéo
tout ça tout ça il ya plein de choses à
dire mais ça on y va maintenant
alors je sais ce pépin lite on en a
quand même pas mal parler j'en ai parlé
il ya quelques temps pour vous présenter
moment où il est annoncé dix jours par
une semaine plus tôt une semaine pour
être précis avant l annonce du p 20 et
du pm un pro c'est un produit qui est
passée un peu à l'aise parce
qu'effectivement le pépin pro a pris
toute la lumière c'est un produit qui
est très fort et très bien placé
néanmoins ce pv wright est vraiment
intéressant comme je vous le dis aux
affaires donnent boxing maintenant on va
faire un test
on va regarder s'il est bien oui non en
termes de photos vidéos et tout ça il va
tout de suite
voilà la bête le huawei p20 lightin
comme je voulais 10 est un smartphone
qui m'a été prêté par ailleurs fun point
com merci à fon de me prêter cette jolie
bête pour pouvoir le tester et
directement montré à tout le monde et
regarder en quoi il est intéressant est
ce qu'il est cool oui non tout ça
longtemps dans cette vidéo c'est que on
va le tester
on va regarder un petit peu l'ol sont
allés fouiner à droite à gauche voir ce
qui est cool moi la question que vous me
posez c'est est vraiment est-ce que ce
notch pose problème oui non est-ce qu'il
est bien est ce qu'il est naze un skill
et marbre comme jeudi et claquent sans
bornes à se mettre sur youtube et on va
regarder
monsieur greu monsieur gros ans a tapé
un entier monsieur heureux là on va se
mettre une vidéo et on va regarder si au
final c'est cool louis leterrier a pas
central park
je suis sur la version je pense non
rognés et si je le vends en version
reliée à ce que je peux l'agrandir et là
je peux pas vraiment dire quoi je peux
pas la vendirent c'est bizarre ça c'est
un truc est très bizarre que normalement
lorsque vous avez un smartphone comme ça
et que vous voulez l'agrandir vous
faites ça il a s'agrandit et là ça ne
grandit pas donc ça veut dire que je
peux même pas utiliser cette partie là
j'ai forcément des bandes noires sur le
côté soixante paraît quand même
surprenant
on va regarder un peu dans les
paramètres ce que ça dit là par exemple
on a deux possibilités on peut soit m
l'encoche par défaut soit masqué
l'encoche et là on l'a pas par contre on
l'a pas mais on l'a quand même un peu
c'est à dire qu'on a les informations
qui sont bien marqués au nom n'a pas le
liseré blanc donc c'est à dire qu'on l'a
cascino glisse quand même la partie au
dessus
j'ai vraiment l'impression que c'est un
peu crasseux fout de la gueule des gens
parce que c'est pas vrai qu'ils
exagèrent ray en disant ça mais là
effectivement vous la voyez vous la
voyez plus il ya quand même les infos
donc on va quand même les objets des
informations dans ta gauche c'est à la
fois assez intelligent et à la fois à la
fois vous
l'utiliser quand même cette partie là on
va avoir les thèmes ça c'est le saphir
les sweet dreams sakura gold et ça c'est
très girly pink intrigue early rien va
se mettre le speed à la petite c'est
joli donc là on va changer de thème
ensuite musique vidéos elles sont dans
une partie sans t on à une application
de santé huawei on a aussi une petite
radio fm dessus alors bon il faut
brancher des écouteurs peut pas profiter
de la radio je ne savais pas sur une
version sur une vidéo d'avant maintenant
c'est beau je suis au courant
alors ici la partie caméra ça ça va être
le côté un petit peu intéressants avec
comme je vous disais une 13 mégapixels
ici à l'arrière et une 2 mégapixels à
l'avant on a ou la petite caméra devant
pour changer hop elle est là salut tout
le monde c'est moi là on a la petite
caméra devant et on va regarder un peu
ce qu'elle est rarement aussi bien
évidemment le flash automatique activé
constants on peut laisser flash
constante d'apprendre des langues torche
tout simplement ici la grande ouverture
activer et désactiver si on a un qui
voit la différence
je suis preneur pour moi je ne joue pas
différence entre la grande ouverture
activer et désactiver
c'est peut-être moi qui y suis un peu on
va dire que voilà un bel essai comme ça
hop ça c'est le mode portrait distance
optimale entre 0,5 et 2 m ok
fonctionnalités image dynamique active
est ok les paramètres
photo photo pro vidéo vidéo pro les
filtres lhd à clichy notamment
panoramique light painting bon ça c'est
un petit peu un grand classique on
retrouve effectivement dans le m8 bien
évidemment de huawei
là on a la résolution donc là on est
encore là mais on 16 mégapixels
ok ça marche le format raw rentre
toujours dans ce même but le minuteur
l'a prise en photo tout chez les souris
ensuite obligé bon ça c'est un grand
classique
on va tester on va voir si la photo est
cool on va le faire des tests en
extérieur donc pour voir la photo et la
vidéo donc lâché côté photo là je suis
côté vidéo
donc pour moi la stabilisation c'est pas
top comme vous le savez j'ai la
tremblote si vous savez pas vous allez
rapidement découvrir l'image bouge quand
même moi je pense que là dessus
la stabilisation faut pas trop y compter
une fois de plus on est sur un produit
qui colle aux produits entrée de gamme
donc c'est normal
bon je suis sur les caméras de celle
fille directement donc je filme
téléphone à la main comme vous le voyez
je crois que ça bouge un petit peu pour
ça c'est c'est pour moi c'est normal
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
alors je la gère l'éclairage en pleine
tronche a donc je suis quand même un peu
un peu très éclairé si je le recul up in
the air gai et de la partie bonjour
reason béria alors on va les tester tous
à 2 1 on va aller voir ce que ça dit
avec la caméra avant la caméra arrière
on va regarder le mode portrait on va
regarder différentes choses en termes de
luminosité voir si c'est intéressant
parce qu'au final qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ces smartphones ont fait essentiellement
des photos ou de la vidéo pour partager
sur les réseaux sociaux on y va bon là
en extérieur toujours sur la caméra
avant donc lever du soleil beaucoup
ainsi plus de 15 ans officiels mais bon
il fait quand même relativement beau
voir si cette caméra va pas trop mal
alors bon il faut être plus on est sur
un smartphone pas très cher on va pas
chercher des choses de dingue
vous vous inquiétez pas un peu plus de
soleil presque presque bronze et
aujourd'hui on est au printemps c'est
quand même plus agréable or maintenant
on va tester la caméra arrière donc la
suite sur la caméra arrière offre un
petit peu le test pour voir si c'est
intéressant ou pas donc ce qu'on va
faire se coltiner ma tronche
il ya des fleurs qui sont sortis orale
et les filmer et on va regarder si c'est
intéressant oui vous rendez pas compte
mais moi je vois sur les trains en tout
cas sur l'écran c'est un espèce de
violine très intense alors qu'en fait on
est sur un truc qui tire plus sur le
bleu la couleur est pas du tout naturel
représente pas du tout c'est sûr saturé
c'est complètement dingue si vous voyez
la vérité la réalité entre ce qu'allait
à l'atteinte de sa qui est sur un viol
et viol est quand même beaucoup plus
foncée de ce que je vois sur l'écran
alors après avoir son moniteur quand je
serai le montage où j'ai un vraiment un
truc qui est vraiment qu'ils tirent un
peu plus sur le le rose
là j'ai un vrai viol est classique un
peu sobre c'est pareil là c'est sûr
saturé de ce que je vois à l'écran
au final ça dénature vraiment l'appareil
pour ça c'est complètement dénaturé
c'est sûr saturé c'est très très très
très très bizarre c'est vraiment c'est
pas du tout la même couleur de ce que je
vois à l'écran
je reconnais pas la fleur au chantage de
moi pareil pour là c'est complètement
saturé alors qu'est-ce que je peux faire
des changements
je clique dessus ça va un peu mieux mais
pareil c'est très saturé là toute la
partie qu'on va à droite est extrêmement
saturer ses limites blanc alors que
c'est dû joindre à la base ça n'a
peut-être pas vraiment si je clique et
gottéron lion noir
après il ya un autofocus dessus ça
marche pas trop mal non mais après
l'autofocus marche patron des relations
va pas dire par contre et c'est là la
stabilisation et à la fois donc il faut
oublier
pas terrible il ya un côté qui est
vachement plus clair les postes clair
que ça sature sont le dessus en tout cas
sur l'écran avoir rendu vidéo finale
c'est vraiment très bizarre
alors là j'ai activé le mode
embellissement je trouve que ça n'en est
rien le traitement logiciel est quand
même un peu bizarre pas très très beau
c'est tout est sursaturé si vous voulez
voir la vie à travers une grosse
saturation et que tout soit un petit peu
loin de la réalité
là vous y êtes aujourd'hui c'est
champagne bucolique je fais le tour des
fleurs du jardin ça c'est pareil à la
limite c'est ce qui aurait serait
presque plus dans leurs rêves et que
j'ai pas de soleil
je fais le point à différents endroits
ça marche bien nombreux se sont
retrouvés pour une fois de plus on n'est
pas sur un tout très très cher les
capteurs sont pas non plus complètement
dingos aux flèches à l'extérieur entend
faire un petit test on va rentrer pour
voir comment ils s'adaptent à
différentes luminosité
l'aop de me suivre je rentre ses sombres
les lumières ne s'allume pas tout va
bien si c'était ça le plus sombre
derrière la mort voire up moyens peu
lumière a qu'à voir si ça marche bien
c'est pas trop saturé donc là je suis
sur le capteur arrière j'y vois
absolument rien en faire le même talent
sans capteur avant ok donc je sens la
voix sur le test pour voir effectivement
comment ils se tapaient la luminosité
sur cette caméra tellement
déstabilisation c'est vraiment cette
envie de vomir presque alors hop voilà
que lui mit à rire un peu moins fort
c'est même à contre jour
non mais du point de vue luminosité ça
va pas trop mal il ya un à dix il a
peut-être bien quand même ça marche bien
snaptu pas trop mal bon ça va bien le
navire ce côté là bon enfin côté photo
j'ai fait quelques clichés peut pas dire
que ça marche pas ça marche plutôt bien
les clichés sont assez bien fait je peux
effectivement zoomer voir un petit peu
profité tout mon écran mais une fois de
plus ce qui est quand même dingue c'est
que je ne vais pas renier directement
son côté de l'encoche parce que au final
la partie de l'encoche là on voit
qu'elle est vraiment dédié uniquement à
voir les informations pour une
notification les choses comme ça mais
pas plus on peut pas l'utiliser comme
sur un iphone à utiliser vraiment tout
le bord ici ça c'est assez c'est assez
surprenant quand même mais bon sinon
après du point de vue photo du pôle de
vidéos ya rien à dire ça marche quand
même plutôt pas mal ou en mode jeu vidéo
ça marche plutôt pas mal on n'a rien à
reprocher après effectivement voilà il
se réchauffe pas je suis pas sur un jeu
qui la consomme énormément c'est un
petit jeu un petit jeu met en cause
quand même dingue c'est vraiment se
retrouver avec la cette grande barre à
gauche tiger en bas à droite
bon voilà c'est logo avoué la ouais ça
c'est vraiment le format qui est un
petit peu particulier
moi le seul truc qui me chagrine
vraiment et que ce smartphone s'est dès
lors vous n'avez pas un format 19/9 et
bien que vous soyez quand même bloqué
vous puissiez pas allez zou met dedans
achemine une vidéo écarté pour passer en
plein écran
voilà là je peux passer en plein écran
là je peux pas tout à l'heure je pouvais
pas et maintenant je peux leur allez
savoir ce qui s'est passé je peux zoom
est donc là effectivement au foyer j'ai
une petite bande en haut une petite
bande en bas là je crois un peu dans mon
image par contre ça n'utilise pas au
niveau de l'encoche ça n'a pas où mais à
fond ça me garde un peu la
proportionnelle entre vraiment une
partie gauche là la même bande à gauche
la même bande à droite la gelée en petit
la gelée en grand et je vais pas
utiliser toute la partie là on dit que
c'est comment ça tu pourras utilisa plus
âpre effectivement ça serait quand même
décalé j'aurais plus à gauche - droite
mais bon ça pourrait avoir un sens soyez
donc au final tout à l'heure ça
fonctionnait pas et là ça fonctionne
allez savoir pourquoi côté batterie la
une diffuse encore un jour et 3 heures
effectivement ça dépend de l'utilisation
ça dépend de la consommation de la
batterie
là pour l'instant je n'ai pas énormément
utilisé il ya un mode de gestion
d'alimentation ultras qui reste 5 jours
et 4 heures après les smartphones en
lui-même une fonctionne plutôt pas mal
hein pas se mentir le karine à 659
répond plutôt bien après je vais
solliciter en vendée gens pas mal de
choses ça marche ça fonctionne c'est pas
non plus une bête de compet c'est pas
non plus le smartphone de l'année on va
pas se mentir pour le prix pour ce qu on
lui demande pour 369 euros marche plutôt
pas mal maintenant la question à se
poser c'est en mai sur un smartphone
quand même d'entrée de gamme d'entrée de
gamme comme à 369 euros
il ya quand même moins cher et des
produits qui sont aussi très bien est ce
qu'il faut aller sur ce pv light c'est
toujours délicat à lire a comparé
également des produits de honor c'est
difficile de faire le choix en attendant
si vous aimez bien ce produit si vous
aimez ce design si vous aimez l'encoche
si vous aimez designer de cas moi je
trouve qu'il est quand même plutôt sympa
plutôt bien réussi on va pas cracher
dans la soupe
le design effectivement toute cette
gamme p20 fait comme ça elle est bien
fait que quatorze empreintes digitales
marche très bien délire où très vite
pour faire des jeux rapides c'est sympa
quelques souvenirs quelques photos
quelques vidéos ça fonctionne plutôt pas
mal voilà pour cette vidéo alors
j'espère vous avoir aidé dites moi ce
que vous pensez est ce qu'au final vous
trouvez cool ce pv wright est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter est ce
que vous trouvez en tout cas de ce que
je vous ai montré il vous donne envie
est ce que vous pourriez changer et si
vous changiez est-ce que vous changeriez
pour ce produit vous ne marquez tout son
commentaire comme d'habitude vous invite
à laisser des jolies pousse à vous
abonner on reste connectés
je vous embrasse soyez sages en sécurité
parce qu'il éprouve à parler toujours
plus de produits tech innovant ya plein
de choses qui va arriver je vous réserve
des surprises je travaille dès
aujourd'hui pour la rentrée du mois de
septembre
vous allez voir en septembre va se
passer des choses on va changer pas mal
de choses avec cool
donc restez connectés je vous embrasse
son message et à bientôt tiens
[Musique]